- All right, everybody, welcome back.
Jenna Bush Hager and Barbara
Bush is still here hanging out.
(audience cheering)
Their new book is called
"Love Comes First,"
in honor of it, and also of some
of the greatest love songs out there,
it's time for a game we're calling
"Love Comes First or at
Least at Some Point."
♪ Love comes first ♪
- Or at least at some point.
- [Kelly] At least at some point.
That's my favorite part.
- Love comes first, or
at least at some point.
Let's write that book.
- We hope.
- I know, poor song.
Jessi is going to play on Jenna's team.
- Yes she is!
(hands clap)
- The losing team.
- Let's go.
- Jessi is a fierce competitor like Jenna,
but we are ready for it.
- We are.
- We are ready.
Okay, Lord, I need a little help.
(ethereal music)
(audience cheers)
- [God] Well, hey there, Kelly.
How you doing, girl?
- I'm doing so good.
- [God] You know I'm here to help.
Now, I don't know about helping you win.
'Cause I hear you're
0 and 2 against Jenna.
I'm not sure my powers can...
- God!
- That's rude.
- God, come on.
- Let's go, let's go.
- [God] I can't promise you.
Just pray on it, just pray on it.
Anyway, in this game,
I'm gonna ask a question
about a famous song with the
word 'love' in the title.
Now you be the first to hit your button
and answer correctly to earn a point.
Steals are allowed, so watch yourself.
And each team is playing
for a mighty prize
for their side of the audience.
- Oh!
- Okay okay.
(audience cheers)
- Let's go!
- [God] Okay, here's your first question.
- Okay.
- [God] In this song, a group B-52's
hopped in a Chrysler.
(buzzer dings)
- Yeah!
- Yes!
- [Kelly and Barbara] "Love Shack!"
(buzzer dings)
- [God] It is "Love Shack."
(audience cheers)
- Ow, my head.
- Okay, we can do the
next one. That was fast.
- [God] Glitter on the
mattress, litter on the highway.
That's just a weekend in Vegas for them.
Okay, here's your next question.
- All right, God.
- [God] Michael Bolton explained
what happens-
(buzzer dings)
- "When a Man Loves a Woman."
- [God] When a Man Loves a Woman
Jessi got it.
(audience cheers)
- Now wait.
- You're amazing.
- That could have been
"Time, Love, and Tenderness"
Love is in there too.
- Michael Bolton sang a lot of love songs.
- Its his vibe.
- He can sing to me.
- [God] Pipe down, Kelly.
Pipe down.
- All right.
- [God] It's a tie so it doesn't matter.
If the phone rings, pick it up
because it might be Stevie Wonder
wanting to tell you how much he-
(buzzer dings)
♪ I just called to say I love you ♪
- [God] It is "I Just
Called to Say I Love You."
- We're winning, we're winning.
(audience cheers)
We are strong.
- I'm sorry, Stevie.
- I know, I'm embarrassed.
- That was an embarrassment.
- [God] Yeah, I'm sorry, Stevie.
I still prefer those chocolate
covered candy hearts.
Okay, here's question number four.
(contestants laugh)
Okay, Dolly wrote it,
but Whitney took it-
(buzzer dings)
- [Barbara And Kelly] "I
Will Always Love You!"
- Yes!
(buzzer dings)
- [God] Unbelievable, it is
"I Will Always Love You."
- We are amazing.
- Is the button not working?
- [Kelly] Are you having a hard time?
Is this not working?
- Oh, it's working.
- [Kelly] Are you having a hard time?
- I thought ours wasn't working,
but they hit it faster.
- [God] There we go.
There's Kelly rubbing it in as usual.
- Yes.
- Per us, per us.
- [God] If you put another
10 cent piece in the jukebox,
baby, you're going to hear Joan Jett.
- Joan Jett, Joan Jett.
- (beep)
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
- [God] Just say her name.
- How much time?
How much time do you get?
(buzzer sounds)
- [God] That's it.
Kelly, you could steal.
- "I Love Rock and Roll!"
- [God] It is "I Love Rock and Roll."
♪ Oh my god, oh ♪
(audience cheers and applauds)
(air horn sounds)
- I'm giving myself a headache.
- You need to calm down.
- That sound means
we have time for just one more love song.
- That means we have already lost?
- No, no, no.
- Not on this show.
- [God] This is your big moment.
- This is winner takes all?
- [God] That's right, that's right.
Because Jenna and Jessi,
you only got one sad little
point there on the board.
- We know.
- Thank you, Lord.
- [God] Barbara and Kelly you got four.
This one is for 5,000 points.
Why not? Okay.
- Okay.
- 5,000.
- Here we go.
This is your last question.
In this song, a promise was made
to hold you tight baby, all
through the darkest hours
by those sexy crooners in Boyz II Men.
♪ I'll make love to you ♪
(buzzer dings)
- "I'll Make Love to You."
And there it is.
- I love it!
(air horn sounds)
- [God] We're outta time.
Barbara and Kelly are the big winners.
- I just needed your sister's help.
- Congratulations.
- Thank you.
- She said no.
- I had to shake.
- I'm not happy for you.
- Congratulations.
- I'm over here, not happy for you.
- I want you to know I
am not happy for you.
- [Kelly] That's why I love you
- I'm gonna have to come back
because I feel as though
I'm gonna need a rematch.
- Okay, we're in the
same building. Doable.
Okay, so we are the
winners, but it's my show.
And when it comes to the audience,
everyone is a winner here.
So design marketplace
Minted offers personalized
holiday cards with unique
designs from independent artists
to help you spread the love this season.
You're all getting a
$200 Minted gift card.
You are welcome.
(audience cheers)
Give it up for Jenna Bush
Hagar and Barbara Bush.
Their new book is called
"Love Comes First."
It's out now.